do you ever eat when you're not hungry
now I'm not talking about those people
that are trying to gain weight I'm
talking about those people are trying to
lose weight now one of the rules that I
recommend in all my videos and my books
is you don't want to eat unless you're
hungry okay and if you're not hungry
don't eat but some people do still eat
when they're not hungry for various
reasons so I want to talk about that
because if you're trying to stick to a
program and you're eating when you're
not hungry
it's gonna be really hard to stick to
that and see results so let's talk about
three things that relate to this first
thing and the most important thing is
being satisfied we know that if you're
on keto correctly and you're doing in a
minute fasting exactly like you should
you are not going to be hungry you're
gonna be very satisfied if you are
hungry and craving and you're not
satisfied that means you're just not
doing it correctly you need to keep your
carbs lower you know fast longer you
need to eat more fat but the fact that
you're eating more fat should be more
satisfying and allow you to go longer
with your in a minute fasting the fact
that you're in ketosis and you're making
ketones because ketones are a natural
appetite suppressant and this other
point right here when you're in ketosis
you are eating your own fat so when
you're fasting you are eating you're
just living off your fat you're not
eating a hamburger you're just eating
your own fat you don't see it but you
are eating so don't feel like you're
starving because your body is eating
24/7 it's just eating your reserves okay
number two your environment how well can
you resist temptation that's the
question on a scale from one to ten ten
being very very disciplined and able to
resist temptation zero being you will
cave at the sight of a doughnut 20 feet
away go ahead and write down the number
and rate how well you're able to resist
things down below in the comment section
I want to see but there's various smells
at restaurants
social pressures from family and
so-called friends who basically just
pressure you into eating some of the
stuff and the visuals of that chocolate
brownie right when they bring this
dessert tray over it's very difficult to
say no not to mention the memories of
all these delicious foods so what do you
do in this situation well you're gonna
have to start to avoid those
environments very important so don't
keep going out to dinner every night
start making food at home start
preparing your meals in advance so you
have some control over that and it's
also very important to get everyone's
agreement in the house not to bring any
junk in the house so you're not tempted
and also you want to have alternative
so-called pleasure foods because
sometimes you might have the
consideration that you shouldn't have to
restrict foods other people are eating
them they're losing weight why do you
have to restrict them well all you have
to do is make an alternative food that's
almost identical like a keto dessert and
that way you can substitute something so
you don't feel like you are restricting
it and then we have these past habits
that you had in the past I don't know
maybe it's snacking at night when you're
bored when you're watching TV you have
to put something in your mouth or you
have this idea that you cannot waste any
food on the plate so you always have to
eat everything in your plate so you go
to restaurant and they make bring this
huge meal and you have to eat everything
right well just gonna have to have
smaller plates and cook for yourself I
already talked about this you have this
consideration that I shouldn't have to
restrict certain foods
well those foods have gotten you in
trouble so you do have to restrict them
but you can also have substitute foods
as well and the other thing is that the
more that you can't have something that
adds pressure and it's gonna make you
want it more so anything you can't have
you want more and you get really serious
about that and that's not really good so
you want to actually have a very light
attitude about that and not be so
maybe fanatical about every little thing
and maybe allow yourself to have it
every so often but just make sure that
you make up the damage so that way
there's not this so much pressure on you
and what I'm talking about making up the
damage is that if you have something
that you shouldn't eat well then going
too fast
take your app cider vinegar take your
nutrients be extra good with your
carbohydrates to allow yourself to reset
now you're probably only going to do
this in the beginning when you start
this program because as you start doing
it it gets easier and easier and more
enjoyable you'll start to enjoy the keto
foods and also the vegetables it really
won't be a problem down the road but the
first thing you want to do is isolate
what is your bad habit okay change your
mind about that's what I did I basically
said that's it I'm done I'm not gonna do
that anymore I would go to the grocery
store this was my habit I would buy
celery and all these vegetables and
everything and I would also buy Pringles
and Doritos and things like that and
pizza so I get home and I wouldn't eat
the vegetables I would have the pizza
and Doritos but in my mind if I had
these other vegetables there I said I'll
eat healthy when I get older okay so I
had to change my mind about that also
you have to use discipline the thing
about using discipline is that every
time that you use discipline and you
succeed by resisting something you will
strengthen your willpower to the point
where it's stronger and stronger because
what really creates a low willpower is
the continual giving into your
temptations so using discipline will
strengthen this thing over time and you
will be able to stick to the program and
also not eat unless you're hungry all
right thanks for watching
hey if you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos